the Joe Rogan experience every idea Joe
here's the bottom line on this thing
every idea that I've just talked to you
about it you're supported by a majority
of the American people these are not
radical ideas let's let's take these one
step at a time cuz you mentioned a lot
of important things there let's go with
the minimum wage thing now the argument
that I've heard about the minimum wage
being raised to $15 an hour is that
their entry-level positions for high
school kids for people that are just
getting their feet wet in the
marketplace they're learning how to work
they're learning they're making some
money after school that they that if you
charge or if businesses have to pay $15
an hour to people like that to
entry-level people that they won't be
able to stay open well first of all they
will be competing against you know if
your business lumber business and both
of us have to raise our wages at the
same level we both have the same burden
so it's right spread across that is what
my conservative colleagues will tell you
the truth is I don't have the numbers
right in front of me
that while it certainly is true that
young people do work at McDonald's and
the minimum wage jobs a significant and
majority of the workers uh not kids they
are often and I met them at McDonald's
they are workers who have children
themselves when we we work very hard to
raise the minimum wage at Amazon and it
Disney we put pressure on both of those
companies and they did the right thing
and when you talk to the people at
Amazon who got that raise these are not
kids these are people in their 30s these
are these are ordinary adults who cannot
make it on twelve thirteen bucks and I
was so I think the argument that all
their old kids is not really quite
accurate well not even that all they're
they're all kids but that if they are
kids what would you think about making a
minimum wage for someone who's under 18
that's different from a minimum wage of
someone who's a legal adult I'm not I'm
not for that I think we do it and and
look many of these young people you know
have their own needs I just talked to a
young woman last night who is working
going to college working full-time
trying to take care of her family as
well so I think look the minimum wage
has not been raised in
that is now $7.25 an hour which is
clearly unacceptable the cost of housing
California all over this country is
rising fairly rapidly people can't
afford health care can't afford College
I don't think it's asking our employers
too much to pay at least $15 an hour
minimum wage now I'm glad you brought up
Amazon because one of the things that
always freaks me out is when I find out
that enormous corporations that make
billions of dollars have tax loopholes
where they literally pay no money how is
that possible and how do you stop that
well it's the same thing as the drug
companies how is it possible that we pay
ten times more for insulin in this
country and for other drugs than the one
in Canada or countries around the world
mmm and the answer is its power so what
is what is the goal of major
corporations in America it's to be
deregulated as much as possible so in
some cases they can pollute our water
our air our environment it's also not to
pay any taxes
Trump campaign as what we call he said
my tax plan is not gonna benefit the
wealthy it's gonna benefit working
people well turns out over ten years
eighty three percent of the benefit at
the end of ten years goes to the top one
percent that's what these guys though I
remember I'm the called the ranking
member on the Budget Committee in the
Senate and some guy came forward
representing one of the big business
organizations and this is their agenda
their agenda was to cut Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid and to do away
with all corporate taxes so what you
have right now that's that's what greed
is about they wanted all so as you
indicated you have a company like Amazon
owned by Jeff Bezos who happens to be
the wealthiest guy in America worth
about 150 billion Amazon paid zero in
federal income taxes and it's not just
him dozens of corporations paid nothing
or very very little and on top of all of
that you got these guys able to stashed
all over the world come trillions of
dollars trillions of dollars in the
Cayman Islands in Bermuda and Luxembourg
and
the tax havens that is insane and that
has gotta end yeah how is it legal to do
that why is it legal Joe it is legal
because they make the laws right all
right
you know m't here you're touching now on
the heart and soul of the tragedy of
American politics how does it happen
that on issue after issue the American
people the working class of this country
wants something nobody pays any
attention to it but billionaires want
something and it gets done and that has
to do with a corrupt political system so
right now if you are the Koch brothers
or some multi billionaire you say to the
leadership of the Republican Party and
in some cases to the democratic money
hey guess what we're prepared to put
hundreds of millions of dollars into
your campaign hundreds of millions of
dollars coming from one or two people
and here is my agenda
I want tax breaks I want a trade system
which will enable me to shut down in
this country and go to China or Mexico
and pay people there two bucks an hour I
want to be able to do more pollution
because I don't like all of this you
know money I have to spend preventing
pollution of the air or the water that's
what I want you to do and by the way I'm
worried about the deficit so you may as
well cut Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid how many Americans actually
believe that we should give tax breaks
to billionaires and cut Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid very few that is
talk to Mitch McConnell get Mitch on the
show that is exactly what he believes
but that's ridiculous right and it seems
that if you just took away those tax
breaks the enormous amount of money that
would come from those corporations
having to pay their fair share would
take care of a lot of the expenses of
all these things that you're proposing
exactly